[Music]
holy mackinaw
punky brewster is back
henry's apartment may look a little
different but some things never change
like all the easter eggs and throwbacks
you'll see in the new peacock original
series
punky brewster let's get started you're
definitely going to see some familiar
faces
starting in the first episode punky
talks to a portrait of henry her foster
father
played by the late george gaines in
season 2 episode 22 of the original
henry gives punky his first camera
hoping she might follow in his footsteps
you can use it for career day good news
henry
she did
henry's hat and pipe can also be spotted
on the console under henry's portrait
[Music]
you washed my pipes
they were filthy inside they're supposed
to be
filthy inside remember brandon
punky's furry companion from way back
when turns out her love for golden
retrievers has not gone away
me brandy punky might be just a few
years older but she still got her punky
power
something else punky didn't leave in
1984 her mismatched shoes
still works and some of her signature
catchphrases
holy macanally holy
we told you you'd see some familiar
faces and it doesn't take long for
punky's childhood best friend cherry
to join her side you're my idol
i am yeah just think
you got your own apartment you can step
slaves you want
and you don't have to go to school
cherry now works at fenster hall the
very same children's shelter that punky
was notorious from running away from
[Music]
fenster hall is also where punky meets
izzy a girl
not so different from her younger self
turns out izzy is also a professional
escape artist is it coast clear
punky is raising her kids in the very
same apartment
where her and henry became a family at
their home you'll definitely see some
throwbacks
like afghan blankets the painted sun in
hannah's bedroom window and
punky's old tree house is back
the same person who created the original
treehouse back in 1984
was brought back to create this new
version doesn't seem as big as it used
to
punky loves a classic while trying to
teach her kids a lesson in the family
car
punky sings along to maniac a nod to
when the young punky sings the song in
the original
and it looks like her dance moves
haven't changed in over 30 years either
she's a media
maniac you never forget your first kiss
or camp kooka loopy in episode 3 punky
reminisces with cherry about her first
kiss i can't do you remember
when jimmy kissed me at the kissing rock
at camp kookaluki let's relive the
moment together
shall we
hmm evan looks familiar right did any
seth green fans notice who played
punky's online date
fun fact this is a full circle moment
for seth
who auditioned for a role in the
original punky brewster and is now
soleil's real life
bestie
one of our favorite moments from the
classic series is when henry lets punky
skip school to go to a cubs game
and gives her a hat just like punky
gives izzy in the reboot
are you serious we told you there were
going to be many familiar faces
margot returns to make izzy's dreams
come true and it seems like she's still
living in the limelight
just like she did when she was young
that's marvel cramer with the k
look for my exercise tape it'll be
coming out soon
in episode 7 punky and the kids adding a
little izzy flair to the treehouse
is just like when henry and punky's
friends helped her in the original
you know what they say the apple doesn't
fall far from the
tree house note to self always
carve initials in your tree house this
is where we carved our initials
today we finished building the tree
house pb
cj friends forever
we all remember the episode when cherry
gets stuck in a refrigerator
but cherry will never forget you eat all
my yogurt
and you have an irrational fear of
refrigerators there's good reason for
that
how long did it take punky brewster to
find a reason to throw an 80s themed
party in the new show
only nine episodes but it was worth the
wait it's gonna be rad
the max
as you can see cherry's headband game
has remained strong
[Music]
if you weren't already convinced that
izzy was basically punky's twin
she dresses up as a young punky booster
and leaves no detailed spare
sun hair ties check miss matte sneakers
obviously
and a skate key like the one punky worn
the original show
you bet if she says punky power i'm a
straight up losing so we know punky
brewster's tv family
but did you know that this girl is
actually soleil moonfry's daughter
jagger take all the raffle tickets you
want here you go free of charge
keep walking sister
saleh moon fry's name is friends for sun
moon
and you may have noticed a sun theme
throughout the show
first in the always present sun in the
apartment window but also in episode 10
when punky and susan show each other
their matching sun tattoos
more nostalgic references is music to
our ears
mine symbolizes the music box you gave
me when i was a little girl with the
song about the sun
punky's music box is the same music box
from the original
and that is punky powerful
now that we've looked at all of the
easter eggs and throwbacks
i think we're gonna sit back and watch
some punky brewster
my punky power says bring it on
[Music]
[Music]
you